uh so when you come in the building
there's no separation of bds gds this
click that's it none of that oh that's
out the door when you come into the
building you can actually be a kid be a
student be free you're not looking over
your shoulder you're not worried about
who's to walk up on you you don't have
to worry about somebody knocking you
upside it's not about any of that it's
all about education meeting you where
you are and helping you be the most
successful person that we could possibly
give
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living inside this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bring to you the issues and awareness
that you need to know about the violence
on the south side of chicago but also to
raise as much money as we possibly can
to build a community center on this
much-needed block called o-block it's
called o-block because it's named after
a young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs picked up the o in
his name and started calling it oh block
we decided we're going to keep the old
but we're going to call it opportunity
block i want to thank fox network for
giving me the opportunity every single
day to bring to you rooftop revelations
where i give you my thoughts viewpoints
and opinions on matters as it relates to
chicago and issues in america today i
have a really really really special
guest and i'm so excited her name is
dion kirksey how are you i am well and
she is the principal of the school that
is located inside our church it is
progressive leadership academy of
a youth connection charter school a
youth connection charter school so at
our church inside our church there is a
charter school called a progressive
leadership academy and they're connected
to
a group of charter schools
and we are so thankful for them but i
want to jump right in okay and i want to
ask you
first of all why was um
progressive leadership academy started
what's the what was the point
our premise was initially to uh service
students that needed a smaller
environment
and a little more individualized
attention yeah
because
and why is that because i i know in
chicago public schools
the classrooms the student sizes are
very large
and sometimes there's students who need
a little more attention for whatever
reason and your school provides that
right absolutely yes so we found that a
lot of students uh could be more
successful in a smaller environment uh
and have that one-on-one attention that
they actually needed
yeah so
let's talk about the school
it's not your traditional school it's a
different school
but but what is it that you all your
your main focus for each student
actually i would say our main focus is
reaching students where they are and
bring them up to bar to be successful
citizens in society yeah do you feel
like uh as a principal that sometimes
you're getting students some not all but
a lot of times that students that you're
getting
sometimes that what do you do when they
are behind when they're when they're
reading not proficient and and i say
that because
we've been doing the studies and we see
that the math levels are not
proficient in chicago public schools a
lot of times and so now here you have
these students who are not proficient so
what is it that you do that's different
so actually we get students from all
facets not just chicago public schools
but other school systems as well
we meet them and try to focus on their
deficiencies so the skill levels where
they are we try to get them up to par
to be successful at the great level that
they should actually be on
right so that's one of the reasons why
you need a smaller more classroom sizes
yes absolutely you know i'm familiar
with the school but those who are
watching are pro are not familiar i know
there are a lot of kids from a lot of
different makeups in the school and
we're thankful for that but one of the
things that i appreciate is that the
school has
a great makeup of woodline students who
are from different
um
cliques or different gang fashions can
you talk a little bit about that because
i want to know how are you able to be so
successful with all of these different
gang factions in the location because it
would seem as if there would be fights
every day
so how do you do that how do you keep it
a good atmosphere so i pride myself in
my team i have an amazing assistant
principal uh carol robinson also my
staff is amazing as well but we all
pride ourselves on uh creating a sense
of family in our building
so when you come in the building there's
no separation of bds gds this click that
said none of that all that's out the
door when you come into the building you
can actually be a kid be a student be
free you're not looking over your
shoulder you're not worried about who's
going to walk up on you you don't have
to worry about somebody knocking you
upside it's not about any of that it's
all about education meeting you where
you are and helping you be the most
successful person that we could possibly
give you that's good that's awesome
so
when you get these students
you get them on
uh a path
and
what is that path normally to like what
are the students i know most of the
students don't go to college some do but
most of them but so what are you
preparing them for these these
specialized students uh we actually are
preparing them to be successful citizens
in whatever capacity that might possibly
be whether it's nails and lashes whether
it's going to lincoln college whether
it's going to kennedy king and working
on your career in early childhood
education where we partner with a
daycare center called brainbox and they
hire some of our students so they're
working and they're in school at the
same time
uh we have masonry forklift driving
coding
um it's a variety of lists of things
that they can do outside of just uh your
traditional four-year college setting
and still be successful still have an
income and you're not on the street all
right that's awesome so
one last question
when you think about the students at
progressive leadership academy
and
them being on a path towards success in
whatever endeavor
what is it that ultimately
you think people would say about the
students of progressive leadership
academy looking looking in
from the outside looking in uh
you really can't tell that it's a hidden
gem
if that makes sense uh
our leadership team sheila vincent and
larry vaughn are absolutely amazing
they've given me my training to actually
do what i do but i would say
nobody really understands what we put
together and how we create a strong
sense of family in the building yeah and
we not only support our kids in the
building and their educational level but
we support support them outside the
building in their endeavors and we still
attend their graduations we send them
off to college and actually decorate
their dorm rooms uh we go to their
babies birthday parties like it's just a
plethora of things that we do just to
engage to have that sense of family
and i think that peace gives us what we
have in the building which is a minimal
to no level of violence yeah
one more thing
um when you think about the school and
you think about the students
do you think
that in chicago with all the violence
that's going on and the school situation
the way it is do you think we need more
charter schools like yours to address
the issues that we're facing if we're
going to solve some of the issues of
violence oh most definitely because
currently a youth connection charter
school has 19 campuses i think if that
was broadened to uh more areas and more
under probably uh privileged
neighborhoods i think we could be much
much more successful we touched maybe
4 000 to 5 000 students a year across
our 19 campuses i think if we had some
additional campuses we could change some
more lives
well awesome well thank you you do a
wonderful job if we had not not just
more schools like yours with more
principals like you i'm sure we'd be
able to help solve issues of uh and help
uh bless a lot of kids and help get them
on the right direction so thank you for
all that you do thank you for serving
the way you serve and um let's keep
doing it thank you it's my ministry all
right so listen as i always say uh
thank you for tuning in to rooftop
revelations and until tomorrow
peace
you